J'ai eu 12 ans sur le tournage de mon premier film
le professionnel dans lequel j'incarnais une
jeune fille qui se lie d'amitié avec un tueur à gages et
espère venger le meurtre de sa famille
le personnage
découvre et développe simultanément sa femme
a entendu sa voix et son désir à ce moment là
moment de ma vie, moi aussi je découvrais
ma propre féminité, mon propre désir et ma
propre voix J'étais tellement excitée à 13 ans lorsque
le film est sorti et que mon travail et mon
art auraient une réponse humaine J'ai
ouvert avec enthousiasme mon premier courrier de fan pour
lire un  fantasme de viol qu'un homme m'avait
écrit un compte à rebours a été lancé sur mon
émission de radio locale jusqu'à mon 18e anniversaire par
euphémisme la date à laquelle je serais
autorisé à coucher avec des critiques de films
ont parlé de mes seins en herbe et
des critiques que j'ai comprises très rapidement même
à treize ans-  ans que si je devais
m'exprimer sexuellement, je ne me sentirais
pas en sécurité et que les hommes se sentiraient en droit de
dégoûter et d'objectiver mon corps à
mon grand inconfort, alors j'ai rapidement
ajusté mon comportement, j'ai rejeté tout rôle
qui avait même une scène de baiser et parlé
à propos de ce choix délibérément dans
les interviews, j'ai souligné à quel point j'étais livresque
et à quel point j'étais sérieux et j'ai
cultivé une manière élégante de
m'habiller.  serait écouté
à 13 ans le message de notre
culture était clair pour moi j'ai ressenti le besoin
de couvrir mon corps et d'inhiber mon
expression et mon travail afin d'envoyer
mon propre message au monde que je suis
quelqu'un digne de  la sécurité et le respect la
réponse à mon expression de petits
commentaires sur mon corps à des
déclarations délibérées plus menaçantes servent
à contrôler mon comportement dans un
environnement de terrorisme sexuel un monde
dans lequel je pourrais porter ce que je veux
dire ce que je veux et exprimer mon
désir comme je  vouloir sans craindre
pour ma sécurité physique ou ma réputation
qui serait le monde dans lequel le
désir et la sexualité féminins pourraient avoir leur
plus grande expression et
signifiait que le monde que nous voulons construire est à l'
opposé du puritain donc j'aimerais
proposer une façon de continuer à bouger  cette
révolution en avant déclarons haut
et fort c'est ce que je veux c'est ce dont
j'ai besoin c'est ce que je désire c'est
ainsi que vous pouvez m'aider à atteindre le plaisir
faisons une révolution du désir